the abalone spend their first six months
in the farms hatchery in nursery pond at
six months of age the abalone is
graduate to the cultivation pod after
six months to a year in the cultivation
pond the abalone e's are mature and
ready for harvesting workers remove them
from the shell and remove organs to be
used for other products then the workers
prepare to extract collagen from the
meat first they mash the meat in an
industrial sized blender the trick is to
use an extraction method that doesn't
destroy the collagen or diminish its
effectiveness abalone collagen must have
full potency when consumed in order to
stimulate the human body to produce more
of its own collagen since prolonged
heating turns collagen into gelatin
workers use a process called cold
extraction stirring the meat in
refrigerated tanks for up to seven days
until the collagen separates and rises
to the top
workers skim off the collagen then to
make this particular product blend it
with mixed fruit juices
then they heat the drink in
pasteurization tanks for three minutes
to kill off any bacteria the drink
contains 20% collagen and 80% chews when
it's time to package the product the
conveyor belt moves glass bottles to the
cleaning station which washes them out
with pressurized boiling water after
washing the bottles move to the next
machine which fills them with the drink
the next machine seals the bottles with
an aluminium twist cap
controlled by a sensor an inkjet printer
applies the lock number on the cap along
with the products expiration date a year
away while this drink is a skin
enhancement product other abalone
collagen formulations are designed for
weight loss boosting immunity increasing
bone density and strengthening cartilage